Bonjour Éric Zemmour et bonne année. Merci bonne
année à tous. Cette fois ça y est, le Royaume-Uni
a quitté l'union européenne et vous affirmez que
les grands gagnants du Brexit ce sont eux les
anglais. Pourquoi ? On peut le dire comme ça. Je dirais pas vainqueurs ou vaincus, je dirais,
effectivement, mais là où vous avez tout à fait
raison c'est que je pense que la Commission de
Bruxelles a été dépassé par elle même. Je vais
essayer d'expliquer pourquoi. En fait depuis
l'arrivée des anglais en 1973 dans le
Marché Commun à l'époque, les anglais ne
se sont jamais départis des mêmes principes.
C'est à dire il sont pour le projet économique
c'est-à-dire le grand marché, le commerce libre
sans droits de douane etc. Et ils sont contre le
projet politique de l'Europe. Une construction
plus ou moins fédérale d'un grand empire
européen qui rassemblerait le continent. Et en
fait le Brexit si on le voit sous cet anglelà,
ce n'est que la continuation par d'autres
moyens du même projet. C'est à dire, on veut
toujours l'économie mais on veut vraiment
pas du politique, c'est à dire des directives de
Bruxelles, de la Commission, des arrêts de la Cour
de justice, de la liberté des personnes
avec les travailleurs détachés tout ça même si
ils n'ont jamais ratifié Schengen. C'est
toujours la même discussion et je constate, alors,
en face, évidemment, souvenez-vous des débuts la
négociation. La Commission de Bruxelles
avait avec Michel Barnier le projet exactement
inverse. C'est à dire on disait aux anglais «vous
ne pourrez accéder aux grands marchés européens
pour commercer librement que si vous acceptez
les arrêts de la Cour européenne de justice et
tout le droit européen». C'était
ça le débat au départ. En fait d'après vous
les négociateurs de Bruxelles sont les victimes
d'une idéologie qu'il aura été instillé par les
anglais ? C'est ça le paradoxe si vous voulez.
On a eu, on sait, il y a eu des dizaines de livres
là dessus. On sait qu'il y a eu deux époques de
l'Europe. Il y a eu le temps du Marché Commun que
je dirais «à la française» avec le tarif extérieur
commun donc la fameuse forteresse
Europe comme disaient les américains. C'est à dire
on fait du marché, on commerce entre nous mais
on a un tarif extérieur commun. Et
puis après à partir des années 80, l'idéologie
libre-échangiste a gagné, enseignée par les
anglais, c'est pour ça que j'ironisais et
la Commission de Bruxelles et l’Europe et
devenue l'agent
de la mondialisation, le cheval de Troie
de la mondialisation multipliant les accords
de libre échange etc. Le résultat
de la négociation c'est que les anglais pourront
accéder aux grands marchés européens sans droits
de douane, donc ils pourront continuer à commercer
comme avant avec tous les pays européens mais
en revanche il ne se soumettront pas au
droit européen, à la Cour de justice et aux normes
européennes. Donc oui comme vous disiez au début,
c'est victoire sur toute la ligne des anglais, le
reste c'est des nuances nécessaires, des
compromis, on dit qu'il faut pas trop dériver par
rapport à ces normes, qu'on va se revoir etc.
Tout ça c'est normal mais dans les grands
principes c'est quand même la Grande-Bretagne qui
a gagné et pour une raison simple, c'est que c'est
comme si la Commission de Bruxelles négociait avec
elle même puisque la Grande-Bretagne c'est
sa mère, puisque c'est celle qui lui
a enseigné cette idéologie libre échangiste et
d'ailleurs dans la foulée les anglais
ont répliqué la plupart des accords de libre
échange, il y en a 77 signé par l'Union Européenne avec
les autres pays. On nous a bassiné avec la force
de négociation de la Commission de Bruxelles, vous
vous souvenez, c'est du vent. Vous ne croyez pas plus
Mais c'est du vent, dans les faits, puisque les
anglais tout seul ont obtenu la même chose que
ce que l'Union Européenne a obtenu. Vous voyez
bien et du vent ça n'existe pas mais c'est
logique et c'est même pas partial ce que je dis vous
comprenez. Dans un monde protectionniste, il est
très utile d'être dans une zone de libre-échange,
puisqu'on commerce à l'intérieur et c'est très
bien. Mais dans une dans un monde de libre-
échange, parce que c'est ça la mondialisation,
il y a plus de droits de douane nulle part. Il y a
des normes différentes,
il y a des accords techniques,oui,
mais il y a plus de droits de douane. C'est bien
le principe même de la mondialisation. C'est ce
qui explique les fameuses chaînes de
valeur etc. Qu'on balade les produits pour faire
une voiture, on vous la balade dans le monde entier.
Si on peut les balader dans le monde entier
c'est qu'il y a pas de droits de douane vous êtes d'accord
avec moi ? Donc qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Et bien ça n'a
plus aucun intérêt dans une zone de libre échange.
Et donc il ne reste que les inconvénients c'est à
dire les pertes de souveraineté. Merci Eric Zemmour